okay so you just laid out the next few
fights Yeah well yeah I mean Cheeto is
obviously next in March where at I don't
know what about what about business what
about it like is there business that you
want to do is there anything like you
got the belt you've achieved it you've
reached the Mountaintop yeah what comes
next um are you in a you like you want
to do movies like I got offered a movie
scene I can't say we signed n can we
allude to it definitely not not but I
turn it down get the Pakistani out of
here okay is it Hollywood or adult
Hollywood hell yeah okay I was like I
look over at well just ask is just
general question you know no I just I'm
not ready for movies yet I'm not I got a
like I said I'm [__] I got a lot to
lot to do and uh beating up Cheetos next
but as far as business wise goes how do
you how do you how does the Cheeto fight
go what do you think what do you
think let me think let me think you go
you think while I talk uh okay you go
you go you go you go I'm going to do the
thinking yeah I think you know
stylistically you know and I think about
I think that's about anybody if I'm
going to be if I'm faster than you
that's why the Cory fight so interesting
because I'm not I don't know if I'm
necessarily faster I think it's pretty
equal but I feel like if I'm faster than
someone it's going to be I can I'm gonna
beat him and uh I think you know I'm
just G be fast too fast for Cheeto he's
he's he's he's tough he's very durable
you know I'm cardio is great cardio is
good I'm not taking anything away from
very tough fight does he great dresser
yeah there a lot of things yeah is there
a mental component going into a fight
with someone that technically beats you
even though there was a obviously a body
malfunction maybe if if he would have
beat me in like a three round fight and
went to decision and he and he just like
beat my ass that'd be like that that'd
be different that'd probably be harder
like for Cheeto to Fight Cory again like
remember when Cory [__] Cheeto up like
for five rounds bad remember
that you guys all remember that you guys
remember that so I'm saying like if that
would have happened like it would have
been that would like [__] like going
into a rematch would be tough but I just
like the fact that I watched the fight
back I was smoking him kicked that
[__] nerve rolled my [__] ass ankle
like four times and I was still piecing
him up with one foot yeah I blitzed him
hit him with a seven piece I step back
and my ankle goes whoop whoop oh wow
yeah yeah my ankles gave out and
[__] but yeah so no I don't feel like
going into this fight mentally I'm
having to D you know battle any demons
yeah yeah yeah the mental component
seems Seems I thought I assumed it would
be tough but I feel like technically
you'll be able to Edge him out I
rewatched that fight today did yeah yeah
and seeing you even battling through the
nerve going you could tell when it
happened like bro yeah what happens then
are you like I'm [__] or you like you
know what I think because it it's
happened to people in the past but their
their the nerve comes back hey guys you
know there's one thing sugar Shan and I
have in common only one probably on the
entire planet and that's if we both
[__] with [__] with prize picks and if
you use the promo code Schultz at sign
up at prize picks they'll match your
initial deposit up to $100 that means if
you put in $100 you get $100 for free
you're already winning and if you're
listening to the akos locks you might be
winning you might also be losing prize
picks.com promo code Schultz let's get
back to the show my my ankle wrap was
too tight and I remember having my coach
in the back telling him before we walked
out like hey you try to loosen this up
this [__] was so [__] tight so when
he hit that nerve I just don't think it
was like able to come back I didn't know
it comes back in the same day yeah yeah
it's it's happened to it happened to I
saw it happened to Jimmy crout his name
was it happened to Izzy right a little
bit but that his foot like my [__] was
straight you just no control over no it
happened to there's a few Fighters
Michael Chandler and Bellator yeah
happened to Henry cejudo against
Demetrius Johnson in the first round his
came back um so if I think if I could
have made it to the end of the round I
think it might have came back but my
ankle wraps were so [__] tight that I
think it just shut it off so who don't
wants some smoke huh he says he does bro
but what too too little you think well
not not just too little I don't really
think that has anything to do with it I
just love telling him he's he short
because I know that he's got little man
syndrome which is real and I just know
it fires him up bro every time and he
watches everything I do he wants to be
me so bad so he's watching right now oh
yeah he wants to be six he was tripping
him without even knowing it on accident
I I brought up the belt I was like dude
they should give you guys like a travel
siiz one you can walk around and he just
immediately goes yeah this a hudo belt
yeah I was like he's not here bro come
on can't help and Henry and aljo took
Henry down four times yeah took me down
how many zero out of out of two did he
go for two shots he did uh so I told
Henry if you want to work on some
wrestling like I'll help
you is crazy so uh but yeah Henry acts
like he wants it but I think they're
going to do Henry versus morab I think
they they'll do that and then kind of
dependent on do you want morab because
he took the jacket he didn't take the
jacket I gave it to him he I thought he
was my jacket
guy it look like he ran your jacket bro
I'll be honest you watch the clip
someone
I handed it to him it looks like he
pulled up on you out of just fear I
thought you were just like
afraid yeah you know tall he is I'm the
first time I didn't feel anything when
you made fun of short guys I'm starting
to think it's a thing toward me a little
bit no I got short
Co no watch the video I handed it to him
ah you check it or something like that
no I thought he was going to hold it for
me yeah until I got needed again yeah
yeah but what about his nose though
what's going on cuz his jacket guy
he
I'm dead ass
watch I handed it to him thinking I was
a [__] jacket guy a [__] okay let's
see he's already on the thing I got to
find it real quick but dude I yeah when
you're in the in the Octagon I've only
ever fought in the Octagon except for
this time so I was in there like you
know your senses are tingling yeah
[__] dicks getting hard nice a little
bit nice what are you packing down there
I'm packing depends like a clicker like
a like a remot like an Apple TV or one
of them one of the bigger Clickers like
the small not like the Roku
one like a clicker you see wait can you
see I already took it
off but yeah look look I handed it to
him you got scared bro you got scared
dude you said yo take the Thriller
jacket run no you want to know what
really happened is uh Tim was right
behind me walking into the off so you
thought morab was Tim I was locked into
I mean I was looking at Al's soul I was
looking at Alo I thought Tim was still
behind me so I take my jacket off and I
to him because I'm locked in with Alo
yeah and I it was morab and has Tim felt
insulted that you confused them at all I
I haven't told him he probably wouldn't
like it he's GNA find out he wouldn't
like it yeah he's not going to like that
but uh you know what about morab I that
dude's funny I think he's genuinely a
good dude I think he's genuinely
[__] and you you have experience too
that's the other thing like when you say
that true I don't think he actually I
don't think I think he just has an
accent oh that but that's tough to tell
yeah no I get that it's so fun I went to
the pi a couple weeks after cuz I had to
do something at the UFC and aljo it was
after I beat alo alo was on vacation and
morab was just sitting at the cafeteria
at the pi by himself just lives what was
he drinking he he literally was just
sitting there there was no food he just
hangs out there okay so what what is
that indicative of it feels like you're
kind of hinting at something I don't
know yeah I guess I don't really know
what I was going with
that yeah he just sitting there though
you know what I mean